You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye and health conditions at early stages. To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an
你知道的，你的眼睛经历了很多。每天阅读、处于昏暗光线中、看屏幕时间太长，这些情况我经常遇到。开车时刺眼的阳光直射眼睛。甚至夜间开车也会导致眼睛疲劳。所以，是的，我们的眼睛承受了很大的负荷。因此，照顾好它们并通过定期眼科检查监测它们的健康状况非常重要。在Specsavers进行99美元起步的眼科检查，以检查它们的健康状况，其中包括OCT眼部健康扫描，这有助于在早期阶段发现眼部和健康状况。要找到离您最近的地点并预约眼科检查
OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers.capsavers.c-a exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind-the-scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi there. Hello, everyone.
包含OCT扫描，起价99美元，请访问specksavers.capsavers.c-a。检查由独立验光师提供。价格可能因地点而异。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极的办公室爱好者播客。每周，我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量的闺蜜故事，深入探讨《办公室》的世界。我们是Office Ladies 6.0。大家好。嗨，各位。
Hello, we have a hilarious lady joining us today on Office Lady 6.0. Yes, we love her. It is comedian Leanne Morgan. Now, you might know her from her New York Times bestselling book, What in the World, a Southern woman's guide to laughing at life's unexpected curveballs and beautiful blessings. Or you might have seen her live because she has been touring the stand-up circuit for years, and now you can catch her very successful stand-up show on Netflix called Leanne Morgan. I'm Every Woman.
大家好，今天有一位非常搞笑的女士加入我们的Office Ladies 6.0。是的，我们非常喜欢她。她就是喜剧演员莉安·摩根。现在，你可能通过她的《纽约时报》畅销书《到底怎么回事：南方女性笑对生活中意想不到的转折与美好祝福的指南》认识她。或者你可能看过她的现场表演，因为她多年来一直在巡回表演单口喜剧，现在你可以在Netflix上看到她非常成功的单口喜剧秀《莉安·摩根：我就是个普通女人》。
It is worth a watch. And now you can see her in her new television comedy show, Leanne. It is premiering July 31st on Netflix. And, you know, Jen and I have both loved watching her stand-up. If you want to laugh at the everyday domestic craziness that we all struggle with, you need to follow her Instagram. Oh, it's so true. So like many of you, Angela and I share comedy clips back and forth with each other.
非常值得一看。现在你还可以在她的全新电视喜剧《莉安》中看到她。该剧将于7月31日在Netflix首播。而且，你知道，詹和我都很喜欢看她的单口喜剧。如果你想嘲笑我们所有人都在挣扎的日常家庭疯狂琐事，你需要关注她的Instagram。哦，真是这样。所以和你们中的许多人一样，安吉拉和我经常互相分享喜剧剪辑片段。
And I would say like two-thirds of them are Leah. Yeah. You know what? I actually want to play one to kick us off that cracked me up. It's Leanne doing stand-up and she's talking about her sister who was going to marry a country club man. Let's hear it. There was never alcohol in our house until.
而且我要说，其中大约三分之二都是莉安的。是的。你知道吗？我实际上想放一段来作为开场，把我逗乐了。那是莉安在表演单口喜剧，她谈到了她要嫁给一个乡村俱乐部男人的姐姐。我们来听听。我们家里从来没有酒，直到。
My sister is a little bit older than me, and she was going to marry late in life, and she was going to marry this hooped-de-do man, country club man. I had to explain to women in North Dakota what that was. Hoop-de-do, you know, country club. Because I'm from a town of 500 people, farming people. We didn't know what, we never seen anybody play tennis.
我姐姐比我大一点，她晚婚，打算嫁给这个花哨的男人，一个乡村俱乐部男人。我不得不向北达科他州的女性解释那是什么意思。花里胡哨的，你知道的，乡村俱乐部。因为我来自一个只有500人的农耕小镇。我们不知道那是什麽，我们从没见过任何人打网球。
I'd see somebody on the, on TV and I'd think, oh, that's the queen and her people. So we didn't know anything about a country club. So she's going to marry this country club man. And you know, some country club people like to drink. So to get her married off, we all started drinking. My little mom and daddy had never drank alcohol. My mom drank a glass and a half of wine and got out of my car and said, I can't fill my arms.
我在电视上看到某个人，我就会想，哦，那是女王和她的人民。所以我们对乡村俱乐部一无所知。所以她要嫁给这个乡村俱乐部男人。你知道，有些乡村俱乐部的人喜欢喝酒。为了让她顺利出嫁，我们全家都开始喝酒了。我可怜的爸爸妈妈以前从不喝酒。我妈妈喝了一杯半的葡萄酒，从我的车里下来，说我感觉不到我的胳膊了。
I love her so much. You know, we have to share. Angela, one day, you just like slid into her DM. I did. And you started messaging back and forth. You're just like, I am a fan of you. Yeah. And it turns out she is a fan of the office. And here on office ladies, we are fans of highlighting funny women. So we said, do you want to come on office ladies and just talk about your career and comedy? Talk about your new Netflix show. And we had such a ball talking with her. And I'm so glad we did. Me too. And you know, we hear about her journey. Her quote, overnight success is about 25 years. She just has been out there putting her comedy up on stage year after year, and we're so happy for her. So why don't we take a break?
我太爱她了。你知道，我们必须分享。安吉拉，有一天，你直接发私信联系了她。是的。然后你们就开始互相发信息了。你就像是，我是你的粉丝。是的。结果证明她也是《办公室》的粉丝。在Office Ladies节目中，我们喜欢突出优秀的女性喜剧人。所以我们说，你想不想来Office Ladies聊聊你的职业生涯和喜剧？聊聊你的新Netflix节目。我们和她聊得非常开心。我很高兴我们这样做了。我也是。你知道，我们听说了她的心路历程。她所谓的“一夜成名”其实花了大约25年。她只是年复一年地把自己的喜剧搬上舞台，我们为她感到非常高兴。那我们为什么不休息一下呢？
And then when we come back, here is our interview with Leanne Morgan. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not mean you have to be a new you. But maybe you want to be a less burdened you, a clearer you. Not a totally new you, but maybe like you just want to hone in. You want to refine. Yeah. I like that. Refine. Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you down, what might be holding you back. You can better understand your relationships, your motivations, your emotions.
等我们回来后，就是对莉安·摩根的采访。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。你知道，新年新气象并不意味着你必须脱胎换骨。但也许你想成为一个负担更轻、思路更清晰的自己。不是完全变成另一个人，而是可能只想精雕细琢。你想变得更好。是的。我喜欢这个。精雕细琢。嗯，心理咨询可以帮助更容易地识别是什么让你感到沉重，是什么在阻碍你。你可以更好地理解自己的人际关系、动机和情绪。
I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things. Mm-hmm. Because those really just add up. Mm-hmm. And they're going to be just fine. Well, and you might need help identifying what are small. all things, what are big things? BetterHelp therapists can help.
我正在努力放下对小事的焦虑。嗯。因为那些积少成多。嗯。而且一切都会好起来的。嗯，你可能需要帮助来识别什么是小事，什么是大事？BetterHelp的咨询师可以提供帮助。
With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. BetterHelp makes it easy to get matched online with a qualified therapist. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's better, H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. Oh, my darling girls. I love y'all both so much. Y'all don't know how much joy y'all have given me.
拥有超过3万名咨询师，BetterHelp是全球最大的在线心理咨询平台，已为全球500万多人提供过服务。BetterHelp让你可以轻松地在线匹配到合格的咨询师。注册并在 betterhelp.com/office-ladies 上享受九折优惠。网址是 better, H-E-L-P.com/office-ladies。哦，我亲爱的女孩们。我太爱你们俩了。你们不知道你们给了我多少快乐。
And I tell you, I'm on planes all the time. And I go to my office, honey. I go to the office and watch it on planes. It's just my comfort. Oh, it makes me so happy. Well, Leanne, I feel like we should share a little bit how we got here, which is, I don't know if you know this. We've been trading messages, but years ago,
我告诉你，我一直在坐飞机。我去我的办公室，亲爱的。我去办公室并在飞机上观看。这简直是我的精神慰藉。哦，这让我太开心了。嗯，莉安，我觉得我们应该分享一下我们是怎么走到这一步的，那就是，我不知道你知不知道。我们一直在发信息，但是多年前，
my niece and my sisters went to see you. Wichita Falls, Texas, because that's the big town near my small hometown. You know, when people say, you're going to town, you drive 26 miles to Wichita Falls. And they saw you, and they were like, Angie, we know you love comedy. You're going to love this gal. She's so funny. And I started following you on Instagram. And I was like, she is the real deal. So funny, so down to earth, so relatable. and I have been a fan ever since. And Jenna, same thing. Jenna, like, was like, oh my gosh, we would trade messages.
我的侄女和我的姐姐们去看你的演出。在德克萨斯州Wichita Falls，因为那是离我的小家乡最近的大镇。你知道，当人们说，“你要进城去”，你得开车26英里去Wichita Falls。她们看了你的演出，然后说，安吉，我们知道你喜欢喜剧。你会喜欢这个女孩的。她太搞笑了。我开始在Instagram上关注你。我想，她真是名不虚传。太搞笑了，太接地气了，太有共鸣了，我从那以后一直是你的粉丝。珍娜也一样。珍娜就像是，噢天哪，我们会互发信息。
We trade your videos. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Oh. I just can't even believe it. I mean, you're saying, like, we keep you company on a plane, but, like, I just
我们会互发你的视频。对。对。对。对。噢。我简直不敢相信。我是说，你一直在说，我们在飞机上陪着你，但是，我刚刚
had the craziest morning with my kids. It was like just all the insanity, the dog ate the turkey sandwich when my back was turned and we couldn't find the drum key. and I'm getting a hot flash. And of course, it's all happening on the one morning. I have something to do at a certain time. And that's what your comedy is about. When I listen to you, it's like you help me laugh at all the insanity that was my morning.
和我的孩子们经历了最疯狂的早晨。简直是一团糟，当我转过身时，狗把火鸡三明治给吃了，我们找不到鼓调音钥匙。而且我正在经历潮热。当然，这一切都发生在一个我必须在特定时间完成某事的早晨。这就是你的喜剧所关注的内容。当我听你的节目时，就像是你帮我嘲笑了我早晨经历的所有疯狂事情。
I love you. Yes. Thank you, my angel. I can hear you in my head. I can hear you talking about my dog eating the sandwich. You would mine that for gold. Yes, I would. I may still do that.
我爱你。是的。谢谢你，我的天使。我能在脑海里听到你的声音。我能听到你谈论我的狗吃三明治的事。你会把这当成创作素材。是的，我会的。我可能还是会这样做。
I may still do that. I've got to come up with a third hour for Netflix by 2027. Okay. I may have to, yeah. You might borrow a little. Well, just DM you all the shenanigans that happened trying to get kids out the door. Because you did that, you did that for years, and we'll just be a refresher course. Yes.
我可能还是会这样做。我得到2027年为Netflix凑出第三个小时的节目。好的。我可能不得不这样做。嗯，你可以把把孩子们赶出门时发生的所有恶作剧都发私信告诉你们。因为你做了那个，你做了多年，我们只需要复习一下。是的。
Yeah. And then now I have two grandbabies, two boys that are two and four. Oh. That are yummy. I bet. But I feel like my best material was when I was y'all's age doing all that. That's, I feel like. And I can talk about menopause.
是的。然后现在我有两个孙辈，两个两岁和四岁的男孩。哦。真可爱。我敢打赌。但我觉得我最好的素材是我在你们这个年纪经历这一切的时候。那就是，我觉得。而且我可以谈论更年期。
That's good stuff too. Yes. That's good stuff. And I'm so glad menopause is kind of having a moment right now. Oh, I know. People are finally talking about it. Yeah. Hallelujah over that.
那也是好东西。是的。那是好东西。我很高兴更年期现在正受到一定的关注。哦，我知道。人们终于开始谈论它了。是的，为此哈利路亚。
I know. I think of our poor grandmothers. You know, no one told them anything. And mine was in a house dress with a landline and she would just twirl herself in it, cooking three meals a day, a little farm woman. And nobody helped her. And she looked 100 when she was 50. You know? And now everybody's so, Lord, Hallie Berry, honey has a lubricant.
我知道。我想起我们可怜的祖母们。你知道，没有人告诉过她们任何事。我外婆穿着家居服，拿着座机电话，她一边转着电话线，一边做着一顿三餐，一个典型的农妇。没有人帮她。她50岁时看起来像100岁。你知道吗？现在每个人都，天哪，哈莉·贝瑞，亲爱的，都有了润滑剂。
And she used to do it, you know, with people. It's a whole new world out there. That's right. The older world. Leanne, now you are a household name, but I don't know anything about you. I know your comedy. I'm a fan, but could you share how did you get into comedy? Like, what was your path?
她过去常常和人们一起做这件事。这是一个全新世界。没错。更成熟的世界。莉安，现在你已经是家喻户晓的名字了，但我对你一无所知。我知道你的喜剧。我是你的粉丝，但你能分享一下你是怎么进入喜剧行业的吗？比如，你的路径是什么样的？
It's been a long journey, isn't that right? It has. I've been doing stand-up now for 25 years. I got started when my baby was 18 months old. I say that. When I actually got paid 50, at the Rotary Club to do the luncheon in Morristown, Tennessee. But from the time I was little bitty all, I wanted to go to Hollywood, and I loved television.
这是一段很长的旅程，不是吗？是的。我做单口喜剧已经25年了。我开始时我的宝宝18个月大。我这么说是因为。当时我实际上在田纳西州莫ristown的扶轮社午餐会上演出赚了50美元。但从我很小的时候起，我就想去好莱坞，而且我热爱电视。
And my little mama, Lucille, is so funny. And my dad's a good storyteller. My grandparents, I was raised in a farming community where my aunts and uncles and everybody was around in and out all day long every day. And they were all funny. And kindergarten, my mama, before the state of Tennessee, changed. it to where you had to be five to go to kindergarten. I went at four because I was born in October,
我可爱的妈妈露西尔太搞笑了。我爸爸是个很好的说故事的人。我的祖父母，我是在一个农耕社区长大的，我的阿姨、叔叔和每个人整天都在这里进进出出。他们都很搞笑。在我上幼儿园时，在我妈妈所在的田纳西州更改规定之前。规定要求你必须满五岁才能上幼儿园。我四岁就去了，因为我出生在十月份，
and I needed a big nap still, and I probably had some accidents. And my mama would say, I shouldn't have sent you, even though you're smarter than everybody there. She said, which was a lie, but anyway, she would tell me that. But she said,
我当时仍然需要好好睡个午觉，而且我可能还尿过床。我妈妈会说，我不该送你去，尽管你比那里的所有人都聪明。她说，这虽然是个谎言，但不管怎样，她会那样告诉我。但她说，
does your tummy hurt? And I'd go, yeah, it does. And she'd say, well, let's watch Hollywood Squares and match game and not go to kindergarten. So I loved television, all of that. And in my little mind at nine or ten years old, I remember thinking I'm going to Hollywood. And then, so I went through life, you know, but scared. And I, you know, didn't have the guts at 18 to get in a car and go to L.A.
你肚子疼吗？我会说，是的，确实疼。她会说，好吧，我们来看《好莱坞方块》和《配对游戏》，不去上幼儿园了。所以我热爱电视，所有这一切。在我9岁或10岁的小脑袋里，我记得自己想过我要去好莱坞。然后，我经历了生活，你知道的，但很害怕。而且，你知道，我18岁时没有勇气上车去洛杉矶。
with $60 in my pocket like people do. It didn't even dawn on me. I didn't even know that was a thing. And then I went on to college and did all that traditional stuff, not well, not well, flailed. What was your major in college? Would you study? I ended up going back because I dropped out and then I went back and I got a degree in crisis intervention counseling under the Child and Family Studies, Human Ecology. And I loved it. I could see you being really good at that. Yeah. Thank you. I wanted to be a therapist,
兜里揣着60美元就出门了，就像普通人那样。我当时根本没多想，甚至都不知道还有这回事。后来我上了大学，经历了那些传统的事情，虽然过程不太顺利，可以说是跌跌撞撞。你大学主修什么？你学的是什么？我后来因为退学又复学了，最后拿到了儿童与家庭研究、人类生态学方向的危机干预咨询学位。我当时非常喜欢。我能看出你真的很适合这个。是的。谢谢你。我以前想当个治疗师，
a family therapist if I didn't make it in Hollywood. And I think I've used that in my comedy. I like studying people and I just observe and I get details, you know, and then I can, can, as a storyteller, I like to have details when I'm telling something. But I married Chuck Morgan and he moved me to the foothills of the Appalachia Mountains and I started selling jewelry. I never used my degree. I got pregnant with my first baby, Charlie, who's 31, who's got my grandbabies. And I started selling jewelry and I don't even care about jewelry.
如果没能在好莱坞闯出名堂的话，我想我会当个家庭治疗师。我觉得我把这种经历用在了喜剧创作上。我喜欢研究人，我擅长观察并捕捉细节，你知道的，作为一个讲故事的人，我在讲述事情时喜欢加入细节。但我嫁给查克·摩根之后，他把我带到了阿巴拉契亚山脉的脚下，我开始卖珠宝。我再也没用过我的学位。我怀上了我的第一个孩子查理，他现在31岁了，还让我抱上了孙辈。我当时开始卖珠宝，而我其实根本不在乎珠宝。
Like women sell Mary Kaye and Tupperware. And I was in women's living rooms, two or three nights a week, schlep in the story around eating, you know, depp and having a ball. And I was talking about breastfeeding and hemorrhoids and all that stuff. And people thought I was funny. And I look back on it and I had my own little comedy club. Because I was up in the, it is in the foothills of the Appalachian Mountains, so I didn't have a comedy club. But I was, I knew stand up was going to be my thing. Because before Chuck and I married, we went out to L.A. to visit my sister. She was living in California. And he took me to the comedy store. I wanted to go to the comedy store.
就像女人卖玛丽凯和特百惠一样。我一周有两三天在女人们的客厅里，四处推销故事，吃着零食，你知道的，聊得热火朝天。我当时在谈论母乳喂养、痔疮和各种各样的事情。大家觉得我挺搞笑的。现在回想起来，我当时就像拥有了自己的小型喜剧俱乐部。因为我在阿巴拉契亚山脉的脚下，所以其实并没有什么喜剧俱乐部。但我当时就明白，单口喜剧将是我的事业。因为在查克和我结婚之前，我们去过洛杉矶看望我姐姐。她当时住在加利福尼亚。他带我去了喜剧商店。我当时就想去喜剧商店。
And I wanted to go in that Hearst on that ghost tour and watch where people have been murdered in Hollywood. And Chuck Morgan said, that's the most morbid, twisted thing I've ever heard. And how do you know about Fatty Arbuncle? It was a comedian, you know, who fell on a woman in burst her bladder. Oh, my Lord. Yes, you can Google that. You know who would know that is Kate Flannery. Kate Flannery, who played Meredith, knows everything about old Hollywood.
我还想坐灵车去参加那个幽灵之旅，看看好莱坞有哪些人曾遭人谋杀。而查克·摩根说，这是我听过最病态、最扭曲的事。你怎么会知道法蒂·阿尔巴克利？他是个喜剧演员，你知道的，他曾压到一个女人导致对方膀胱破裂。哦，天哪。是的，你们可以去谷歌一下。你知道谁会知道这些吗？是凯特·弗兰纳里。饰演梅雷迪思的凯特·弗兰纳里，对好莱坞老电影的事无所不知。
She's just like a walking encyclopedia. And she'll throw something like that out there. And you're like, what? The bladder burst, huh? I love that stuff too. I'm right there with her. Bugsy Siegel or Sal Minio got stabbed in a alleyway. But I went to the comedy store and I came alive and I had this.
她简直就像个行走的百科全书。她会突然抛出诸如此类的事实，然后你会想，什么？膀胱破裂，是吗？我也很喜欢这些东西。我和她完全聊得来。小虫西格尔或者萨尔·米内奥在小巷里被刺了。但我去了喜剧商店，我整个人都活过来了，我当时有这种感觉。
I mean, I just thought I can do that. I know I can do it. Anyway, I had my first baby and then I'm schlepping this jewelry and the jewelry company noticed and started getting me to ask to not perform. I was supposed to be doing a speech. teach about how to get booked or in advance, because I was booking about a year in advance these jewelry parties. Because people loved you. Yeah. And we'd have a ball, you know, and they could buy a pair earrings for 1999, you know. Yeah, yeah. Put a little gold on, change your look. So that kind of
我的意思是，我当时就觉得我能做到。我知道我一定能做到。不管怎样，我有了第一个孩子，然后我一边推销珠宝，珠宝公司注意到了我，开始让我去进行非表演性质的活动。我本来应该做一个演讲，教别人如何提前预约演出，因为我当时的珠宝派对预约已经排到大约一年之后了。因为大家都很喜欢你。是的。我们总是能玩得很开心，你知道的，她们可以花19.99美元买一副耳环，你知道的。对，对。戴点金色，换个造型。所以这种经历
gave me the courage there because I was in front of all these women and they, you know, and I was talking about breastfeeding again. And that gave me the courage. And then my husband sold his business. that we had and we moved to San Antonio, Texas for him to work for a big company, and I had a comedy club, and I started doing open mic. I went from open mic to they let me open, and then they put me up at midnight. I had three little children by then they put me up at midnight when everybody's home, marijuana. And I would be talking about somebody do, dude, on a teabow field or going to Weight Watchers. How did the marijuana crowd like that? Some of them liked it.
给了我勇气，因为我站在所有这些女人面前，而且，你知道的，我又在谈论母乳喂养。这给了我勇气。后来我丈夫卖掉了我们的生意，我们搬到了德克萨斯州圣安东尼奥，为了让他去一家大公司工作，我在那里找到了一个喜剧俱乐部，并开始表演开放麦。我从开放麦开始，到他们让我做开场嘉宾，再后来他们把我的演出时间排到了午夜。那时我已经有三个小孩子了，他们在午夜所有人都在家、甚至可能在抽大麻的时候让我上台。而我要讲的内容是关于某人在蒂博球场上的所作所为，或者是去参加减肥俱乐部的经历。大麻观众对那种表演反应如何？有些人喜欢。
Some of them didn't. But I said this the other day, my comedy, I think if you've ever been in a family, if you've had a mama, a grandmama, you know, you kind of relate, you know, to what I'm saying, which is I'm lucky for that. But anyway, and then I just, from there, I became a stand-up. But I raised my children. I got to raise my children. And we moved back to Knoxville for my husband's job at corporate.
有些人不喜欢。但我前几天说过，我的喜剧，如果你曾在一个家庭里生活过，如果你有一个妈妈、一个外婆，你知道的，你多少会产生共鸣，你知道我指的是什么，我很幸运能拥有这一点。不管怎样，从那以后，我正式成为了一名单口喜剧演员。但我抚养了我的孩子们。我得以抚养我的孩子们。后来为了我丈夫在企业的工作，我们搬回了诺克斯维尔。
And I just tried to do what I could. y'all to stay on stage and there was some bad times and there were some good times. Hollywood would come around. They'd want a development deal. Wouldn't make it. I'd take to the band overeat. Then I couldn't get booked. Then I'd get booked.
我只是尽我所能去做所有能留在舞台上的事，期间有过低谷也有过高潮。好莱坞会找上门来。他们想要一个剧本开发协议。结果没谈成。我就会通过暴饮暴食来发泄。然后我就接不到演出。接着又能接到演出。
I mean, I'd have consistent work. And I mean, it was very up and down. I got a lot of nose. But, you know, I just stayed on stage wherever I could. A lot of those were corporate, private, horrible things. and fundraisers. I was your fundraiser girl. But I did clubs throughout when I could,
我的工作时断时续，可以说是起伏非常大。我遭遇了很多拒绝。但是，你知道的，只要有机会，我就会留在舞台上。其中很多演出都是企业年会、私人活动、糟糕透顶的场合，还有筹款活动。我简直就是你们的“筹款活动女王”。但只要有机会，我还是会在俱乐部演出，
but it was hard with three little children. And then really and truly, y'all, this did not blow up until I was about to quit and was so discouraged. I was in my early 50s. And I said, because I'll be, I can't even say it. I'll be 60 in October. I'm really having a hard time.
带着三个小孩子确实很难。说实话，各位，这件事直到我快要放弃、感到无比沮丧时才真正火起来。那时我已经五十出头了。我说，因为我——天哪，我甚至有点说不出口。我十月份就满60岁了。我真的觉得挺难接受的。
Oh, come on now. You're looking awesome. You're crushing it. You're seriously, everybody I know is talking about. you. So bring it on, 60. Come on. Well, you angel. Well, I had my premiere the other night from my television series that's dropping. And my face, I've never seen myself like that. And I thought, where did my chin go? And then Kristen Johnson, who plays my sister, said, don't let that get in your hand laying in.
哦，得了吧。你看起来状态棒极了。你太火了。真的，我认识的每个人都在谈论你。所以，60岁，放马过来吧。来吧。你这个小天使。好吧，前几天我迎来了即将播出的电视剧的首映礼。我的脸，我从来没见过自己在镜头前是那个样子的。我想，我的下巴去哪儿了？然后饰演我姐姐的克里斯汀·约翰逊说，别让这种外在的东西困扰你。
It's about being funny. Think a Carol Burnett making faces. You know, you cannot worry about that. But at first, the shock was a lot. But I saw that premiere the other night. And every expression, I feel like I'm doing my, I'm just twisted up, but I was also so scared. I couldn't even, I mean, I'm sure that was Fright and 59 years old. But anyway, I don't know how I got off on that tangent. This is office ladies. We love a tangent here, Leanne.
关键在于搞笑。想想卡罗尔·伯内特各种做鬼脸。你知道的，你不能去担心那些。但一开始，那种冲击感确实挺大的。不过我前几天看了那个首映礼。每一个表情，我都觉得自己表现得，整个人都扭曲了，但我也真的吓坏了。我甚至无法——我的意思是，59岁时那种惊恐绝对是真实的。不管怎样，我不知道自己怎么就扯到这个话题上去了。这里是“办公室女士”播客，我们最喜欢在列恩这里跑题了。
It's what we do. We're ladies. We're going to talk about a scene between Dwight and Michael. And next thing you know, we're talking about the fact that I had one boo. that made more milk than the other. I don't know how we got there, but we get there. Oh, y'all, that is my kind of talk. I love talking about breast milk.
这就是我们的风格。我们是女士。我们本来要讨论德懷特和迈克尔之间的一个场景，结果聊着聊着，就聊到了我的一边乳房分泌的奶水比另一边多的事。我不知道我们是怎么扯到那儿的，但我们就是能聊到这儿。哦，天哪，这绝对是我最喜欢的话题。我太喜欢聊母乳了。
And I love talking about Michael, and I love all of that. Oh, my gosh. Well, you know what? Jenna and I have talked a lot about just our journey to get here. You know, we're not from Hollywood, you know. I'm from a small town. My family's from Texas and Louisiana. Jenna is a St. Louisville.
我还喜欢聊迈克尔，喜欢所有这些。哦，天哪。你知道吗？詹娜和我经常谈论我们走到今天这一步的历程。你知道的，我们不是来自好莱坞，你知道的。我来自一个小镇。我的家人来自得克萨斯州和路易斯安那州。詹娜来自路易斯维尔。
You know, no one in our families ever did anything like this. The thought of like going across the country to California, are you crazy? So we know what it takes to just keep at a dream that people around you kind of question. But do you remember the moment that you were like, oh my gosh, this is like the turning point. Like I can actually maybe have a career in this. Was there a moment? In stand up or television? or just stand up when I got my first development deal.
你知道的，我们家族里从来没有人做过类似的事情。一想到要横跨整个国家去加利福尼亚，你疯了吗？所以我们深知，要坚持一个周围人都会质疑的梦想需要付出什么。但你还记得那个让你觉得“天哪，这就是转折点，我可能真的能在这行闯出一番事业”的时刻吗？有过这样的时刻吗？是在单口喜剧界、电视界，还是仅仅在单口喜剧界当我拿到第一个开发协议的时候？
It was with Warner Brothers and ABC, and it was right for that first writer strike. Do you all remember that first writer's strike that was awful? But I had a call come in from Mike Clements, the producer, and he worked with Tom Warner, the dead, Roseanne, all those shows. And he said, we think we can, we know we can build a sitcom around you.
那是和华纳兄弟以及美国广播公司合作的，就在第一次编剧大罢工之前。你们还记得那次糟糕透顶的第一次编剧大罢工吗？但我接到了制片人迈克·克莱门斯的电话，他曾与汤姆·华纳、《罗斯anne》以及所有这些剧集合作过。他说，我们觉得我们可以，我们知道我们可以围绕你打造一部情景喜剧。
And I had done my first 45 minutes. I had, you know, back then it took 10 years to get the first 45 minutes for stand-ups before social media and all that. And I had done, you know, I had done a few little touring things and gotten some attention. But when they called and said, we know we can build a sitcom around you, I thought, okay, I'm not crazy. I'm not one of those little children on American Idol that thinks they can sing. You know, it took something like that to validate. Now, it did not make it that writer's strike hit, and it was over in second.
我当时刚完成我的前45分钟演出。你知道的，在社交媒体和这一切出现之前，单口喜剧演员往往需要花10年时间才能攒够前45分钟的演出内容。我当时做过一些小型巡演，也获得了一些关注。但当他们打电话来说“我们知道可以围绕你打造一部情景喜剧”时，我想，好吧，我不是疯子。我不是《美国偶像》里那些觉得自己会唱歌的小朋友。你知道的，需要类似的事情来证明自己。不过，那并没有成功，因为编剧大罢工爆发了，一切瞬间结束了。
and I was devastated. But then I had them after that. And it would be times when I just could not get booked and, or I could get booked, but it wasn't what I'm doing now or anything like that. And, but there would be some little something come along that would give me the hope to keep going. I talk to, like, aspiring actors a lot. I go to universities or classes. And, and, and it's a hard thing to explain to your family at home because they only see the milestones that actually end up on television or end up on stage. But there are so many of those moments, like a development deal, but that actually doesn't happen, but it is still a turning point. And it is the thing that keeps you in it. I had so many roles I didn't get, but maybe it was like
我当时心碎极了。但后来我还是陆陆续续接到了一些机会。有时我就是接不到演出，或者虽然能接到演出，但并不是我现在做的这种或者是类似规模的。不过总会有一些小小的转机出现，给我继续坚持下去的希望。我经常和有抱负的演员们交流。我去大学或表演班做讲座。要向家里的亲人解释这件事其实很难，因为他们只能看到那些最终上了电视或登上舞台的里程碑时刻。但其实有那么多那样的时刻，比如一个最终未能成型的开发协议，但它依然是一个转折点。正是这样的事情让你得以留在这一行。我有过很多没能拿下的角色，但也许它就像是
a callback to a level of producers that I hadn't gotten to before. And that was the validation that I needed to not give us. I had a big audition. This is before the office. It was for a movie, and I couldn't even believe I had the audition, and I didn't get it. On my way there, they called me, and I had prepared and prepared and said, you know what, the offer went out to Jennifer Aniston, and she took it. So I didn't even audition, and I called my mom. I was so heartbroken because I'd worked so hard, and I was like, Mom, they offered it to Jennifer Aniston, and she said, oh, honey, your disappointments are getting bigger.
进入了更高级别制片人的复试环节。这就是我需要的、能够让我坚持下去的认可。我曾有过一次重大试镜。那是在《办公室》之前。是一部电影，我甚至不敢相信自己能得到试镜机会，结果我没选上。就在我去的路上，他们打电话给我，我明明已经做了充分的准备，他们却说，你知道吗，这个角色已经发给詹妮弗·安妮斯顿了，她接了。所以我连试镜都没去，然后我给妈妈打了电话。我当时心碎欲绝，因为我付出了那么多努力，我说，妈妈，他们把角色给詹妮弗·安妮斯顿了，而她说，哦，亲爱的，你的失望越来越大了。
That's a good sign. Like, what? I was like, okay. I love that, though. Good night, Jennifer Aniston. I mean, that was a big deal. I know. I didn't even know you could offer something to people, you know?
这是个好兆头。就像是，什么？我当时想，好吧。不过我很喜欢这个说法。晚安，詹妮弗·安妮斯顿。我的意思是，那可是个大制作。我知道。我甚至不知道你还能直接把角色邀约给别人，你知道吗？
I was so green. I was like, what? That just happens? But yeah. And I was like, okay. All right, Mom. You're right. Next.
我当时太涉世未深了。我就想，什么？这种事居然真的会发生？但确实如此。当时我就想，好吧。好吧，妈妈。你是对的。下一个。
I don't know how y'all done what y'all done. I see I've auditioned just for a few things, and I know I'm not good at that. my baby child, who's 27, had to do it under a ringlight here in the dining room, and she tried not to roll her eyes. Well, I did it. But I don't know how y'all done it. I think y'all've got the hardest job in the world. I don't stand-ups hard, but I don't know.
我不知道你们是怎么完成你们所做的一切的。你看，我只试镜过几次，而且我知道我在这方面并不擅长。我的小女儿，她今年27岁，不得不在这里的餐厅里，在环形灯下帮我录试镜视频，她努力让自己不翻白眼。好吧，我完成了。但我不知道你们是怎么坚持下来的。我觉得你们做的是世界上最难的工作。我觉得单口喜剧很难，但我不知道。
I think what y'all do is harder. Really? I think what you do is harder because somebody else writes all the words for me. Like, I don't have to come up with the material. I just have to deliver it. that's what's so fascinating to me about stand-up comedy is like you have to do the whole thing. Like how do you do that? But Jana, if you did the turkey sandwich and the baby turned their bag, the dog got the turkey sandwich,
我觉得你们做的事更难。真的吗？我觉得你做的事才更难，因为有人帮你写好了所有的台词。比如，我不需要自己想素材。我只需要把它们演绎出来。而这正是我觉得单口喜剧最迷人的地方，因为你必须一个人包办所有环节。比如你怎么能做到这一点？但是詹娜，如果你做了火鸡三明治，结果宝宝把三明治弄脏了，狗吃了火鸡三明治，
you lived it, you saw it, you could write it, and then you could say it. And you'd remember it. When I got the television series, I was, you know, calling home and crying and saying, I cannot learn this script. What in the world? And people go, but you do your act hour and 20 minutes every night. I go, yeah, but I lived it. I wrote it.
你亲身经历了，你看到了，你把它写下来，然后你就能把它讲出来。而且你还记得住。当我拿到这部电视剧时，我当时（你知道的）打电话回家哭着说，我根本记不住这个剧本。这到底是怎么回事？然后别人会说，但你每天晚上都能表演一个小时零二十分钟的个人专场啊。我说，对，但我那是亲身经历的。是我自己写的。
I know it. And I talk out of my butt sometimes and change it up. Yeah. And they said to me, you'll build this muscle. It's a muscle land. And I was like, no. And they're right, though. You do.
我知道。有时候我也会胡说八道，然后临时改词。对。他们对我说，你会锻炼出这种肌肉的。这就像一块肌肉，莱恩。我就想，才不会呢。不过他们说得对。你确实会。
You kind of build that memory muscle of learning lines. By the end of it, I thought, okay, I know there's a rhythm and a way to do this. And they did hire a woman who was from heaven to help me. then we worked like meals. Yeah, it's so helpful to have someone to run lines with you. And, you know, I have to say my husband says that he can tell, like, if I get an audition, and now everything, you have to set up a camera at home and, you know, do it. I'm like, what am I doing?
你差不多会建立起背台词的肌肉记忆。到了最后，我想，好吧，我知道这里面是有节奏和方法的。他们确实请了一位天使般的天使来帮我。然后我们像吃大餐一样努力工作。对，有人陪你对台词真的太有帮助了。而且，我得说，我丈夫说他能看出来，比如说，如果我得到了一个试镜机会——现在所有事情你都得在家架好摄像机，然后拍下来。我就想，我在干什么呢？
Now I'm running a casting session. Are you kidding? You know, and I think that's, it is sometimes harder to learn lines that are not a natural way to speak or a natural cadence. and like I always joke I could never be on ER. Now that's great writing, but I couldn't say pulmonary, get the tube, cardiac code 49. I don't know. Like, no one would believe that.
现在我都在主持选角了。你在开玩笑吗？你知道的，我觉得有时候要记住那些不符合自然说话方式或自然语调的台词真的很难。就像我总是开玩笑说我永远演不了《急诊室的故事》。那剧本写得真棒，但我可说不出“肺部的，拿管子来，49号心脏代码”这种话。我不知道。总之，没人会相信的。
I'm never getting cast on that show. But I hear you. It is like it's a challenge sometimes to learn these lines, but it's a lot easier when they're your lines that you already know are funny. Mm-hmm. And sweet people on my show. are trying to learn how Southern people speak. Oh.
我永远也不会被选中演那部剧。不过我懂你的意思。背这些台词有时确实是个挑战，但如果台词本身就是你自己的，而且你本来就知道它们很好笑，那就会容易得多。嗯。而且我剧里那些可爱的人啊，正在努力学习南方人的说话方式。哦。
But, you know, they just don't know. They just, they can't help it. They've never lived in the South, but they were sweet about saying, Lynn, would you say it a different way, let us know? You know, and so I would rewrite a little bit. And these writers, you know, say things in such a flowery way that I'm just so country. I just don't say that in that way, but they would be very sweet. And it would help me if I could change a little bit.
但是，你知道的，他们就是不懂。他们没办法，他们从来没在南方生活过。不过他们人很好，会说：“莱恩，如果你觉得换个说法更好，请告诉我们。”你知道的，所以我就会稍微改写一点。这些编剧呢，总是用那种非常华丽的方式表达，而我这个人太乡土气息了。我根本不会那样说话，但他们人都很好。如果我能稍微改一下，对我真的很有帮助。
Yeah. No. But the movie that I, you know, I've only done one movie. It's a huge movie. Yes. So many big movie stars. I know. Can you believe that, y'all? I know.
对。不。不过我演的那部电影——你知道的，我只演过一部电影。那是一部超级大片。是的。有那么多大牌电影明星。我懂。你们敢相信吗，各位？我懂。
On Office Ladies, we love a behind the scenes tidbit. Do you have a behind the scenes tidbit of working with Reese Witherspoon and Will Ferrell? I did a movie with Will Ferrell. Oh, honey, Blaze of Glory. He's the best. Yes. Oh, my gosh. I said somebody the other day, they go, what do you want?
在《办公室女士》播客里，我们最喜欢幕后花絮了。你有什么和瑞茜·威瑟斯彭以及威尔·法瑞尔合作的幕后花絮吗？我跟威尔·法瑞尔合作过一部电影。哦，亲爱的，《冰刀双人组》。他太棒了。是的。哦，天哪。前几天我跟别人聊天，他们问：“你想要什么？”
What would you want to do? And they were talking about Nona's, how successful. Well, Nona's, the show, they had so much heart, and women of a certain age on it with Vins Fawn. And they thought that might be something in the vein I'd want to do. And I said, yes, that with Blades of Glory or Talladega Nights. Could I do that with Nona's? Because those are so of my favorites. But, yeah, Will Ferrell was a doll.
你想做什么？”他们谈到了诺娜（Nona's）的节目有多成功。好吧，诺娜的那个节目，充满了人情味，还有文斯·沃恩这样的一群中年女性在里面。他们觉得这可能是我会想尝试的路线。我说：“是的，就像《冰刀双人组》或《塔拉迪加之夜》那样。我能跟诺娜一起拍那种片吗？”因为那些都是我的最爱。但是，对，威尔·法瑞尔真是个甜心。
He's a sweetheart. Oh, sweet. And we just walk on set. And there was one thing where they wanted me. to say something nasty about a man's hearts. And I call that doings. And
他是个大好人。哦，太甜了。我们一走到片场。有一次他们想让我——
men's doings or somebody's doings. We call it business. Your lady business. I don't need to talk about your man business. Well, I don't know how I started calling it doings. Like lady doings, I could say, men's doings.
对男人的隐私部位说些刻薄的话。我把那叫作“生理物件”。而且——
And Will would walk on sit and just go, yeah, doings. At me. But let me tell you, Little Reese Witherspins, one of the smartest people I've ever met in my life. And everything she's ever said to me, it was right.
男人的隐私部位，或者某个人的隐私部位。我们管这叫业务。你的女士业务。我不需要谈论你的男士业务。好吧，我不知道我是怎么开始管它叫“物件”的。就像女士物件，我可以说，男士物件。
So if she tells me to do something, I do it. And that little thing, you know, tiny. And she'd look up at me. And at first I said, it's like, you're like looking at Elvis. She goes still. I go, yeah. And then by the end of it, we were talking about, how much magnesium are you taking at night?
而威尔会走到片场，冲我喊：“耶，物件。”针对我。不过我跟你说，小瑞茜·威瑟斯彭是我这辈子见过最聪明的人之一。她对我说过的每一句话，全都是对的。
Can you poop? I can't poop. Can she poop? What's she taking? She doubled her magnesium. I mean, we were all talking about the same stuff. But that next door was from heaven and just let me riff. And I just loved it.
所以如果她让我做什么，我就会照做。那个小个子，你知道的，个子小小。她会抬头看着我。起初我说，这感觉就像你在看着猫王。她问：“依然如此吗？”我说：“对。”然后到了最后，我们在讨论：你晚上吃多少毫克镁？
And I wish I could do that again. And I was so scared and freaked out, just nervous. But I wish that I could do that all over again because I think I could do it better. I didn't know how things worked. Little Fortune Thamester of the comedian looked at me and said, there's a piece of tape on the floor land. Go stand on it. That's your mark.
你能拉出来吗？我拉不出来。她能拉出来吗？她在吃什么？她把镁的摄入量加倍了。我是说，我们都在讨论这些乱七八糟的事。不过隔壁那位简直就像天使一样，随性发挥就行。我太喜欢了。
I love fortune. What? But everybody there was so helpful to me. But let me tell you when they called me and said, Reese Witherspoon and Wilfair, I want you to do a table read for a movie. I went, what's a table read? And I was getting off a stage to, I was doing a casino in Pennsylvania that Janet Jackson had just been to, which thrilled me.
我真希望能再来一次。当时我吓得要死，整个人都崩溃了，紧张得不行。但我真希望这一切能重新来过，因为我觉得自己这次能做得更好。我以前根本不懂这些运作方式。喜剧演员小福琼·芬姆斯特看着我说：“地上有一条胶带，莱恩。去站上去。那是你的标记。”
And they said, you're going to. got to get on a plane, we'll switch your plane flying, and go do this table read. And I was scared to death, but I did it, and I had a ball, and everybody was there. I didn't know how all that worked. And then I got, I had to get, this is comedy. One minute you've got your foot in the back of an Uber and a baby's diaper, some little mama's ride, drive an Uber, and you've got your foot in a Burger King's sack or a dirty diaper. The next minute you're doing a table read with Wilfair and Ries Witherspoon, and then the next day, you fly to Georgia to do, hey, how, Tyra, Georgia.
我爱福琼。什么？但那里的每个人对我都太好了。不过跟你说，当他们打电话给我，说瑞茜·威瑟斯彭和威尔·法瑞尔想让我为一部电影去读剧本时，我说：“什么是读剧本？”当时我刚下舞台——我在宾夕法尼亚州的一个赌场演出，珍妮·杰克逊刚在那里演过，这让我兴奋不已。
I don't know what that fundraiser was, but I got on a plane and I sat next to Machine Gun Kelly. So I'm on the plane, little Machine Gun Kelly. And I said to my kids, I got Machine Gun Killer sit next to me and they go, he would be flying private, Mama. There's no way. And I go, well, he's six foot seven.
他们说：“你得去赶飞机了，我们帮你改签航班，去参加这个读剧本活动。”我当时吓得要死，但我还是去了，而且我玩得很开心，所有人在那儿。我根本不懂这到底是怎么运作的。然后我得去——这就是喜剧。上一秒你的脚还在Uber后座上，旁边是一个婴儿的尿布，某个新手妈妈开着Uber，你的脚踩在一个汉堡王纸袋或脏尿布上；下一秒你就在和威尔·法瑞尔、瑞茜·威瑟斯彭一起读剧本；再下一天，你就要飞去佐治亚州去参加什么活动——嘿，你好，泰勒，佐治亚州。
He's got a size 15 shoe. He's got on a bunny house. had that bloody looking. It wasn't real blood. It just made to look like blood. And I said, there's some things hanging out of his eyebrows. And they go, okay, that's probably machine gun Kelly. And I said, normally I don't talk to people. I promise I don't, but I went, Megan, you know, he's had that volatile relationship with Megan. Oh, no. I said, you're not going to believe this. She's from Oak Ridge, Tennessee, right where I've raised my children. He went, what? That's effing sick. So anyway, I sat and bonded with machine gun killing.
我不知道那是个什么筹款活动，但我登上了飞机，就坐在机枪凯利旁边。所以我在飞机上，旁边就是小机枪凯利。我对我的孩子们说：“我旁边坐的是机枪凯利。”他们说：“他肯定坐私人飞机啊，妈妈。不可能。”我说：“好吧，他身高六尺七（约两米）。他穿15码的鞋。他穿着一件毛茸茸的房子……身上有那种血淋淋的东西。那不是真血。只是做得看起来像血。我说，他的眉毛上还挂着一些东西。”他们说：“好吧，那大概就是机枪凯利了。”我说：“我平时不跟别人说话。我发誓我真的不跟人说话，但我还是开口了：‘梅根，你知道的，他和梅根有过那种动荡的关系。’哦，不。我说：‘你绝对不会相信这个。她来自田纳西州橡树岭，正是我养育孩子们的地方！’他喊道：‘什么？这他妈太疯狂了。’”所以不管怎样，我和机枪凯利坐在一起，聊得很投缘。
and had a ball, but it was like four days of just crazy mess happened. And you're like, what is my life right now? What is my life? Yes, Jenna and I text each other that because these moments happen where it's like one day, you know, you're just trying to find the shoes for camp at Walmart that everyone wants and you can't find them and your cart's got the weird wheel and all the stuff. And then the next day, it's like, okay, I just sat in first class next to Alicia Keys. do I say hi to her? What do I do? Does she watch the office? I don't know what to do. And also,
玩得可开心了。但那就像是连续四天发生了各种疯狂的烂事。你会想：我这到底过的是什么生活？这算什么生活？是的，珍妮和我经常发短信互相吐槽这个，因为总会有这样的时刻发生：前一天，你知道的，你还在沃尔玛到处找大家都在抢购的营地鞋，却怎么也找不到，购物车轮子还是卡顿的，诸如此类。然后第二天，就变成了：好吧，我刚刚在头等舱挨着艾丽西亚·凯斯坐着。我该跟她打招呼吗？我该怎么办？她看《办公室》吗？我不知道该怎么办。而且还有，
I forgot all my comfortable underwear and I'm going to land in New York with no underwear. Like, these are your lives. It's just wild, isn't it? It's wild. And that's why I wrote a book that almost killed me. And I named it, what in the world? Because I feel like every day I go, what in the world? And now I know Leanne, and by the way, my sister actually took a phone. of her reading that book by the pool and texted it to me. I'm telling you, the Kinsey women, they are going to your shows, they are buying your stuff. They love you so much. And they can't believe I'm talking to you today. They're just so tickled about it. I know how much Jenna's friendship meant to me through all of it because now we started, we were not famous, you know,
我把所有舒服的内衣都忘在家了，我马上就要光着屁股降落纽约了。你看，这就是你们的生活。简直太疯狂了，对吧？太疯狂了。这就是为什么我写了一本差点把我累死的书。我给它取名叫《这到底是怎么回事？》（What in the World?），因为我觉得自己每天都在说：“这到底是怎么回事？”现在我认识了莱恩——顺便说一句，我妹妹甚至拍了一张她在泳池边读那本书的照片，然后发短信给我。我跟你说，金西家族的女性们，她们都在去看你的演出，她们在买你的周边。她们太喜欢你了。而且她们简直不敢相信我今天能跟你通话。她们对此兴奋得不得了。我知道珍妮的友谊对我的意义有多重大，因为当初我们刚开始的时候，我们可不是什么名人，你知道的，
we didn't think the office was going to make it. We didn't even stop our other jobs after the it because we didn't know what was going to happen. And so much of the fame part, a red carpet, a table read, what do you wear, how do you stand, where do you put your hands, do you do the smile so you look constipated or do you do, show your teeth? Like, we found all of that together. We failed together. We had little triumphs together, but I couldn't imagine doing it without her. Do you have your core group that, that kind of, is it, is it a group of gals? Is it Chuck? Is it a combo? In stand-up, I've got, I call her Little K, but Karen Mills and I have traveled together on and all since 2004. And she has been my ride or die. If I had a horrible gig and called her
我们甚至不觉得《办公室》能火。演出结束后我们甚至都没有辞掉原本的工作，因为我们根本不知道接下来会发生什么。关于名气的那一部分，红毯、读剧本、你穿什么、你该怎么站、手该往哪放、你是该笑得像便秘一样还是该露出牙齿？诸如此类。我们是一起摸索出这一切的。我们一起经历失败。我们一起取得小小的胜利。但我无法想象如果没有她，我要怎么度过这一切。你有你的核心朋友圈吗——那种，是一群闺蜜吗？是查克吗？还是组合式的？在单口喜剧界，我有——我叫她小K，凯伦·米尔斯（Karen Mills），我和她从2004年起就一直一起到处巡演。她一直是我的生死之交。如果我演出糟透了，在回家的路上打电话给她，
on the way home and said, I think I need to quit. She would talk me out of it. Then she called me the next week and say, I'm going to quit and I'd talk her out of it. And if I didn't have a dig, like if she did a booking, she'd say, you need to get Leigh and Morgan next. And I would do that for her. And we kept each other going. And I call her and I'll go, what do you think about this material? And when you look at my Netflix special, both sets and see which one, you know, what material you like out of both, she is my stand-up. And then now that this is
说：“我想我得退出了。”她就会劝我打消这个念头。然后第二周她打电话给我说：“我要退出了。”我又会反过来劝她。如果我没有演出——比如如果她接了通告，她就会说：“下一个你得让莱恩和摩根去。”我也会为她这么做。我们就这样互相支撑着走过来。我会打电话给她，然后说：“你觉得这段素材怎么样？”当你去看我的网飞（Netflix）专场时，两套演出你都可以看看，然后选出你最喜欢哪一段素材。她就是我的单口喜剧支柱。然后现在，这是
my TV series, which, you know, I'm scared of death. It comes out July 31st. And I know how, y'all got to help me through that. Because I just, I want people to love it. And I don't know. and, you know, just the uncertainty of it all, and I'm hysterical. But Kristen Johnston plays my sister, and we had immediate chemistry. And, you know, Lord, she's been on every sitcom mom and Third Rock from the Sun and righteous gemstones and in movies and, you know, and she has helped me so much. She taught me, I didn't know all this camera blocking and all this stuff.
我的电视剧集——你知道的，我紧张得要死。它将在7月31日上线。我知道你们得帮我度过这一关。因为我只想让大家都喜欢它。我不知道……而且，你知道的，这一切都充满了不确定性，我简直歇斯底里。不过克里斯汀·约翰斯顿（Kristen Johnston）在剧中扮演我的妹妹，我们俩一拍即合，立刻就有了化学反应。而且，天哪，她演过每一部情景喜剧里的妈妈，《歪星撞地球》还有《请出示红宝石》，还有各种电影。你知道的，她帮了我太多了。她教会了我——我以前根本不懂这些镜头调度和所有这些东西。
And they'd say something. And I'd go, hold on, that's a Hollywood word. what does that mean? And she would tell me and tell me how things should work and encourage me. So she's been sent from heaven. I couldn't have done that if I hadn't had her on this 16 episodes. I told her in our press junket, I had a press junket for the first time. I've never been so tired in my life. I felt like I had the flu when it was over. Oh yeah, you're just mentally like tapped out by the end of them. I was like, I don't know if anything I said made sense. Did I say words? I don't know.
他们会说一些专业术语。我就说：“等等，那是好莱坞黑话，那是什么意思？”然后她就会告诉我，教我事情该怎么运作，并鼓励我。所以她真的是上天派来的天使。如果在这16集的拍摄中没有她在，我根本不可能完成。我在记者会上对她说过，我人生中第一次经历记者会。我从来没这么累过。结束的时候我感觉自己像是得了流感。哦，对，到最后你的精神状态简直就像被榨干了一样。我当时就想：我说的话哪怕有一句是有逻辑的吗？我刚才开口说话了吗？我不知道。
we were all just crazy. You know what? You know Malora, who plays Jam on The Office. She has been an actress and she was a kid. She was on Little House on the Prairie. And her mom and dad are both actors. And so of anyone in our cast, she was truly the most seasoned. And I remember I did my first kind of press junket for a movie.
我们当时都快疯了。你知道吗？你知道梅洛拉（Melora）吗？她在《办公室》里扮演简。她从小就是个演员。她演过《草原小屋》。她的爸爸妈妈也都是演员。所以，在我们剧组的所有人当中，她绝对是最有经验的一个。我记得我为一部电影做我的第一场记者会时，
And it was over the week. that we were shoot in the office, and she said, you look so beat up this morning. And I said, oh, I had this press junket. And I was describing it to her because, you know, they take you to a hotel and you sit in a chair in front of a poster of your thing, your movie, your TV show, and then just one after the other, different reporters come in and ask you almost the same questions, but you have to be fresh and funny and interesting and delightful and sound like you've never said it before and you do that for two days. And it makes you feel a little bit like you're in a dream state. Like, am I talking? Is that my voice? What is happening? Well, Malora, she was like, well, didn't they get you the hotel room
那正好赶上我们在拍《办公室》的那周。她那天早上看着我说：“你今天看起来状态太差了。”我说：“哦，我今天有个记者会。”我当时正跟她描述呢，因为你知道的，他们会把你带到一家酒店，让你坐在一张椅子上，面前摆着你的海报——你的电影、你的电视剧的海报，然后不同的记者一个接一个地进来，问你几乎一模一样的问题，但你必须表现得神采奕奕、风趣幽默、引人入胜、甜美可人，还要让人觉得你从来没说过这些话，而且你得连续两天重复这个过程。这会让你觉得自己有点像在梦游。我在说话吗？那是我的声音吗？这到底是怎么回事？好吧，梅洛拉当时就说：“难道他们没有给你在酒店开一间房，
at the hotel so that you could take a nap and be by yourself during lunch? And I said, no. She goes, oh, Jenna. She goes, they won't get it for you. but if you ask for it, they will. So she started coaching me on all these ways that I could ask for space and like self-care. She was like, you have to have that lunch break completely alone, no one in the room with you, lay in a bed in the dark. Or you're going to go crazy. You're going to go crazy.
好让你在午休时能小睡一会儿、独处一会儿吗？”我说：“没有。”她说：“哦，珍妮。”她说：“他们不会主动为你安排的。但如果你主动要求，他们就会给你安排。”于是她开始教我各种如何争取个人空间和自我照顾的方法。她当时说：“你必须拥有完全属于你自己的午休时间，房间里不能有任何人，你要躺在黑暗的房间里，躺在床上。否则你会疯掉的。你会疯掉的。”
So I was so grateful that we had Malora. She really helped us like understand that it's okay to have boundaries and to take care of yourself and that you can only be your best self if you have had rest or even a water or, you know, things that I was like, oh, we can ask for a chair? I didn't know that, you know, while you're waiting in the wings. And when you're just starting out, you're just so eager to please, you know? And I think especially as women, too, you don't want to be branded as difficult. And so it's like there's all these ways that you can kind of just get, I don't know, maybe even a little taken advantage of. I can say that.
所以，我真的很感激我们有梅洛拉。她真的帮我们明白了设立界限和照顾自己是多么重要，只有当你得到了充分的休息，甚至喝了水——或者做好了其他准备时，你才能展现出最好的自己。以前有些事情，比如我就在想：“哦，原来我们在候场的时候可以要一把椅子？”我以前根本不知道这些，你知道的。当你刚出道的时候，你太渴望去讨好别人了，对吧？而且我觉得尤其是作为女性，你也不想被贴上“难搞”的标签。所以这就意味着，会有各种各样的途径让你不知不觉地——我不知道，甚至可能有点被占了便宜。我可以这么说。
And I didn't, and everybody was wonderful to me, but you're right. Well, Leanne, can you tell us about your show? We're so excited. We want our listeners to hear all about it. It's called Leanne. Yes. And it's going to be on Netflix. It's a half-hour comedy.
而且我没有——每个人对我都很好，但你说得对。好吧，莱恩，你能给我们讲讲你的节目吗？我们太激动了。我们希望我们的听众能听到关于它的一切。它叫《莱恩》（Leanne）。是的。它会在网飞（Netflix）上播出。这是一部半小时的喜剧。
Is that? I think these episodes are really around 17 to 20 minutes, my darling. You know, because there's no commercials. They're going to drop all 16 the same day. Okay. Ooh, so we can binge it. Benj it. Benj it.
是这样吗？我觉得这些单集实际上大概只有17到20分钟，亲爱的。你知道的，因为没有商业广告。他们会把全部16集在同一天一次性放出来。好吧。噢，所以我们可以一口气刷完！一口气刷完！一口气刷完！
Please binge it. Yes. Everybody binge it. They said, tell everybody to binge it. And then I'm telling everybody on stage every night that I have a live show. I go, please run it while you're vacuuming in the background or while you're putting something in a crop pot. I'll just turn it on when we leave for the day and just let it. And then recycle.
请一口气刷完吧！是的。每个人都去一口气刷完。他们说：“告诉所有人去一口气刷完。”然后我每天晚上在现场演出时都会告诉台下的每一个人。我说：“请在你们背景里吸尘的时候放着它，或者在慢炖锅里炖东西的时候放着它。”只要我们出门了，就把它打开让它放着就行。然后循环播放。
Yes. Every day. I mean, that's how people watch the office, honestly. Because it's so comforting. It's my friend. Yes. Tell us about the actors on it and what's sort of like the premise of it. Okay.
对。每天都放。我是说，人们看《办公室》其实也就是这么看的。因为太治愈了。它是我的好朋友。对。给我们讲讲里面的演员，还有它的故事设定大概是怎样的。好吧。
The premise is. that my husband has walked off and left me for another woman after 34 years. And I'm in my, you know, late 50s. And I'm a mother and a grandmother. I'm taking care of elderly parents, trying to launch children. And then this has happened. And like, now what in the world's going to happen to me now? And I think what Chuck Lori was thinking, I thought, I didn't want it to be based on my real life, because that would be weird. You know, me and Chuck Morgan are still married. Yes. But my fans went crazy. You know, as soon as they told what the premise was.
故事设定是：
People were going, Chuck Morgan can't deal with her success. That's what's happened. Oh, no. People blurred the line. My little daddy, who's 85, one of his friends who was 90, called him and said,
我丈夫在结婚34年后抛弃了我，跟另一个女人跑了。而我正处于——你知道的，快60岁的年纪。我是一个母亲，也是一个祖母。我要照顾年迈的父母，还要操心把孩子们抚养独立。然后这件事就发生了。就像是：现在到底有什么倒霉事要落在我头上？我想查克·洛尔（Chuck Lorre）当时的想法是——我当时想，我可不想让它基于我的真实生活，因为那样太怪了。你知道的，我和查克·摩根（Chuck Morgan）现在还结着婚呢。是的。但我的粉丝们都快疯了。你知道的，一旦他们知道了剧情设定，
I'm so sorry, Jimmy, that Lan's getting a divorce. And Daddy said, do something. And I go, Daddy. It's like Beverly Hillbillies. You know, that was not true. Right. But anyway, Chuck Lori just said,
大家都在说：“查克·摩根肯定是受不了她的成功。事情就是这样的。”哦，不。人们把现实和虚构混淆了。我85岁的老父亲，他有个90岁的朋友打电话给他，说：
Lynn, because I had a bit in my net, special talking about if I had to get out and date again because I've got a friend who had to date. And in the Netflix special I say, or my other friend when we were talking about dating, she said, I think I could show somebody my left breast. But anyway, he said, I think that's a common thing, not just like if somebody got divorced, but starting over. Yes.
“吉米，听到莱恩要离婚的消息我太难过了。”我爸爸说：“去你的吧。”我说：“爸爸。”这感觉就像《贝弗利山庄人》里的情节一样。你知道的，那根本不是真的。对。不管怎样，查克·洛尔只是说：
Like, you know, everybody, things happen in life and kicks you in the teeth. And everybody has to start over doing something if it's another career or whatever. y'all, I've got to tell you, I don't mean to be sappy, but when this blew up and I started getting big tours and all that in my 50s, women would say on social media like, this has inspired me. If you can do this, if this can happen to you after all these years, then I can go back to school. I can start a business I've always.
“莱恩，”因为我在网飞专场里有一个段子，讲的是如果我不得不重新出去约会，因为我有一个朋友不得不去约会。我在网飞专场里说：或者我另一个朋友在讨论约会时，她说：“我觉得我可以向某人展示我的左胸。”不管怎样，他说，我觉得这是一个很普遍的情况，不仅仅是针对离婚的人，而是关于重新开始。是的。
I can start a non-profit. So my very first tour of the big panty tour, Vanity Fair panties, did a thing with me on tour where women could submit what they, like if they wanted to see money for a business or to go back to school or whatever, they gave five women the money to do whatever they wanted to do in midlife to start over again. That's wonderful. And so, Lori knew all that. Leanne, I'm getting choked up. Yeah. And I'm telling y'all, I should have gotten a therapist. When all this started happening to me, it was so much bigger than comedy. Women would say to me, you got me through a divorce.
就像，你知道的，每个人生活中都会发生各种各样的事，给你沉重一击。每个人都得从头开始做点什么，不管是开始一段新的职业生涯还是别的什么。各位，我得告诉你们，我不是故意煽情，但当这件事彻底火了、我在50多岁开始大范围巡演时，女性们会在社交媒体上说：“这激励了我。如果你能做到这一点，如果这种事能在经历了这么多年的岁月后发生在你身上，那么我也能重新回去上学。我可以创办一个我一直想开的企业……”
I watch you at night. I'm going through chemo. I've lost. of my parents or whatever. And I would just, it would be so hard to receive that. I think I'm not worthy. I would think I'm not good enough for these precious people. I would get out on stage. I would not even say a word.
“我可以创立一个非营利组织。”所以我的第一场“大内裤”巡演——“名利场（Vanity Fair）内裤”——在巡演期间跟我合作了一个项目，女性们可以提交她们的愿望，比如如果她们想要资金来创业或者重返校园等等，他们为五位女性提供了资金，让她们在中年时期去做她们想做的事，重新开始。这太棒了。所以，洛尔知道这一切。莱恩，我都哽咽了。是的。而且我告诉你们，我本来应该去看心理医生的。当这一切开始发生在我身上时，它的影响力远远超出了喜剧的范畴。女性们会对我说：“你陪我度过了离婚的至暗时刻。”
They would stand up and blow kisses at me and do a standing ovation for every set of word. And what I think it was is that I think that my demographic has been ignored. I think that Hollywood kind of ignores them. I think that there's no other comedians in my lane. I hit a niche where it's just a bunch of darling, fun women out in the middle of the United States and their precious husbands and a half-sip golf pull-up who just want to talk
“我晚上看你的节目。我正在做化疗。我失去了父母之一，”或者诸如此类的话。而我当时会觉得——要承受这些真的太难了。我觉得自己配不上。我会觉得自己不配拥有这些珍贵的人。我走上舞台。我甚至不用开口说一个字。
about normal lives. So anyway, Chuck Lori just said, I think, Lynn, it would be, we need something in there with conflict. And you and Chuck have been married all these years. You all are still together. Your kids are intact. They're doing well. You've done a good job, lady. Yeah. Yeah. But he said we need some, you know, everybody's got to be flawed. And we're flawed, but you know what I mean. So then he said, I think this premise, and it kind of fought it, I kind of just thought, I don't know about that. I don't know.
她们就会起立，向我飞吻，每一个字、每一段演出都能赢得她们的全场起立致敬。我想这背后的原因在于，我认为我所代表的这个群体一直被忽视了。我觉得好莱坞有点忽视了她们。我觉得在我的赛道上没有其他女喜剧演员了。我切入了一个细分市场，这里有一群可爱、有趣的女性，她们生活在美国的中部地区，还有她们可爱的丈夫们，以及一个半醉半醒的、打高尔夫球的男人，他们只想谈论
It doesn't feel authentic to me. And then I thought, well, that's crazy. I don't want it to be based on my real children. You know, that would be terrible for them. So we went with it, and Ron Stiles plays my husband who has left me, but he is so lovable in this. and we wanted him to be, I wanted there to be redemption and forgiveness.
普通的生活。所以不管怎样，查克·洛尔当时就说：“我觉得，莱恩，这其中需要加入一些冲突。而你和查克已经结婚这么多年了。你们俩还在一起。你们的孩子很完整。他们过得很好。你干得不错，女士。”对。对。但他又说我们需要一些——你知道的，每个人都必须有缺陷。我们也是有缺陷的，但你们懂我的意思。所以他说，我觉得这个设定……我一开始其实还有点抗拒，我当时就想：我不太确定这个设定。我不知道。
Ryan is so funny too. I'm so thankful that you're surrounded by these good people. I know, well, honey, they put a bunch of pros around me because they knew I was, you know, green didn't know what I was doing. And I wanted, because I'm a church going, girl, and I do Zumba and I'm done jazzercise many a time in a Presbyterian gym. That's right. So we've got a lot of those kind of scenes that I wanted to be authentic, you know, for like real church scenes.
这让我觉得不够真实。然后我想，好吧，这太疯狂了。我可不想让它以我真实的儿女为原型。你知道的，那对他们来说太可怕了。所以我们还是采用了这个设定，而罗恩·斯泰尔斯（Ron Stiles）在剧中扮演抛弃我的丈夫，但他在剧里非常讨人喜欢。我们希望他能——我希望剧里能有救赎和原谅。
And so Jima and there's all these women, like there's a book club scene. But anyway, it's really based on real life and, you know, some of my comedy, my sensibility. But I think it's got hard. But I think it's something people can relate to. But I think it's funny. I think it's funny. And it's different than anything I've ever. seen before. And Leanne, the character Leanne, explores the idea of maybe dating again.
瑞恩（Ryan）也特别搞笑。我很庆幸你身边能被这些好人环绕。我懂，好吧，亲爱的，他们在我的周围安排了一群专业人士，因为他们知道我当时——你知道的，是个新手，根本不知道自己在干什么。而且我希望——因为我是个去教堂的女孩，我跳尊巴（Zumba），我还在长老会的体育馆里跳过很多次爵士舞（Jazzercise）。没错。所以剧里有很多那种场景，我希望它们能足够真实，你知道的，就像真正的教堂场景一样。
Oh, hey. Can you imagine if you had two? No, no, no. I can't imagine. No. So a lot of that, yes. And I feel like if I do get another season, I can be more equipped to be, because I am a writer on it, and executive producer. I feel like I can give more now that I've been through this first rodeo. And you know what? All of the firsts are done. You know, fortune telling you where to stand on the tape. That's done. It's like a learning curve and you're getting it. And it was the same for Jen and I. We're all still learning. And that's the thing Jen and I talk about is that you're never too old to be curious. Like you don't age out of being curious, you know? And I think a lot of your stand-up, it does speak to people who are like maybe a little part of them that they dream they tucked away. And you're just, you're just, you know, and I think a lot of your stand-up, it does speak to people who are like, maybe a little part of them that they dream they dreamed they tucked away. And you're just, and you're just just like, no, no, no, those dreams, they can live and they can come to fruition. And I just think it's so inspiring. Thank you, my darling. Well, and people ask me all the time about all of that.
所以吉玛和剧里有各种各样的女性，比如有一个读书俱乐部场景。不管怎样，它确实是以现实生活为基础的，还有，你知道的，我的一些喜剧风格和感知力。但我认为它很有深度。而且我觉得这是人们能产生共鸣的内容。但我认为它很好笑。我觉得它很好笑。而且它跟我以前见过的任何东西都不一样。莱恩，“莱恩”这个角色在剧中探索了可能再次约会的想法。
And I do say, I mean, you have to take risk. You have to persevere. You know, I went through a whole stage during stand-up when it was big comedy central. And that's, I was not what they wanted. You know, I was a mama with a pair of kitten hell's own, with caprice, with birds of, on them. I tell people, I was not comedy central. But you have to
哦，天哪。你能想象如果你有两个吗？不，不，不。我无法想象。不。所以这其中有很多内容，是的。我觉得如果我能拍第二季，我能准备得更充分，因为我是编剧之一，也是执行制片人。我觉得经历过这第一次“牛仔竞技”之后，我现在能付出更多了。你知道吗？所有的“第一次”都已经完成了。你知道的，福琼告诉你该站在胶带的哪个位置。那已经完成了。这就像是一个学习曲线，你正在逐渐掌握它。珍妮和我当时也是这样的。我们大家现在都还在学习。而这正是珍妮和我经常讨论的事情：你永远不会老到失去好奇心。就像你不会因为年龄增长而失去好奇心一样，你知道的？而且我觉得你的很多单口喜剧，确实触动了那些人——或许他们内心深处藏着一个自己曾经小心翼翼收好的梦想。而你只是，你只是，你知道的——而且我觉得你的单口喜剧确实触动了这样的人：他们内心深处可能藏着一个他们梦想中的、以为自己已经藏起来的愿望，而你只是在告诉他们：不，不，不，那些梦想，它们可以活过来，它们可以实现。我真的觉得这太鼓舞人心了。谢谢你，亲爱的。嗯，人们总是向我询问所有这些事情。
persevere whatever it is that you want to do in your life. And I also think you only get one time around this world. Why not give it? I mean, you know, what do you got to lose? If it doesn't work out, it doesn't work. I tell you all who inspires me. I watch him all the time on
我确实说过，我是说，你必须冒风险。你必须坚持不懈。你知道的，我在单口喜剧的某个阶段经历过，当时喜剧中心（Comedy Central）非常火。而我，并不是他们想要的那种类型。你知道的，我是一个穿着猫跟鞋、穿着带有小鸟图案的七分裤的妈妈。我告诉大家，我可不是喜剧中心那种风格的人。但你必须
Instagram or whatever it comes up on. Steve Harvey. Steve Harvey talks about being homeless. But you got to jump off that cliff. There's a bunch of things he talks about, but you've got to, if you do take that leap, you are going to get bruised and bloody and all that, and there's going to be a bunch of nose and a bunch of, but you're not going to know until you jump off of that. And one day, it's going to work and it's going to go. And I just, you know, I, yes, I'm 59. I'm worried that I look like I don't
坚持不懈地追求你在生活中想要实现的任何目标。而且我也觉得，在这个世界上你只能走一遭。为什么不放手一试呢？我是说，你知道的，你有什么好失去的？如果行不通，那就拉倒呗。我告诉你们所有谁最激励了我。我经常在Instagram上看到他——无论什么时候刷到他：史蒂夫·哈维（Steve Harvey）。史蒂夫·哈维谈到过自己曾经无家可归的经历。但你必须纵身跳下那座悬崖。他谈到了很多事情，但你必须——如果你真的迈出那一跃，你肯定会摔得青肿流血，会遭遇一堆“拒绝”和各种挫折，但如果你不跳下去，你永远不会知道结果。而总有一天，它会成功的，它会运转起来的。我只是——你知道的，我，是的，我已经59岁了。我很担心自己看起来像
have a chin. And I'm telling you all, my fanny was pretty big on that screen. I knew I had a big fanny. I didn't know it was, I mean, I thought you could set a cafeteria. trying on my pain. This is the hard part, I think, about our industry, which is that when you're just at home and you're being a mom and you're taking care of people, you're not like looking in the mirror all the time. I remember I went through this big stretch where Angela and I were just podcasting. We're not on camera.
没有下巴一样。我告诉你们所有人，我的屁股在那个屏幕上显得可太大了。我知道我本来屁股就不小。但我不知道它居然——我是说，我当时觉得你甚至可以在上面摆个自助餐厅。尝试我的痛苦。我觉得这是我们这个行业最艰难的部分，也就是当你只是待在家当妈妈、照顾身边的人时，你并不会总是照镜子。我记得我经历过很长一段时间，安吉拉和我当时只做播客。我们不上镜头。
It's just our voices. It was like five years, the pandemic. And then I got this part in Mean Girls, the movie. movie musical. I sat down in the hair and makeup trailer and I had not looked at myself in a mirror for 90 minutes straight in five years. I couldn't believe what I was looking at. I was like, what is that vein on my neck? When, where has, has that been there? Like, is anyone else worried about it? I did not know that vein was bulging like that. Can you cover that with makeup? I don't know. Like every wrinkle, every sag was suddenly like, and I thought, oh, this is, yeah, this is because I have not looked in a mirror for a long period of time.
只有我们的声音。那大约持续了五年，也就是大流行期间。然后我在电影音乐剧《贱女孩》（Mean Girls）里得到了这个角色。我坐在化妆间的椅子上，我已经连续五年没有连续90分钟好好照过镜子了。我简直不敢相信自己看到的一切。我当时就想：我脖子上那根血管是什么情况？什么时候——它一直在那儿吗？有没有其他人也在担心这个？我根本不知道那根血管凸显得这么厉害。能用粉底把它遮住吗？我不知道。就像每一道皱纹、每一处下垂，突然间全都——我心想，哦，这是，是的，因为我太长时间没有照镜子了。
Or if I'm taking a selfie, I just throw a filter on it. My skincare routine is a filter. My skincare routine is soap and some oil of allay. Yeah. That is my moisturizer. And it doesn't even have, it's not even regenerist. It doesn't even have a hydrox. whatever in it or the retinol, it has none of that. It's like the mildest whatever I got at
或者如果我在自拍，我就会加个滤镜。我的护肤流程就是一个滤镜。我的护肤流程就是肥皂加一些玉兰油。对，那是我的保湿霜。它甚至都没有，它甚至都不是再生系列的。里面甚至没有羟基什么的或者视黄醇，一点都没有。就像我在
Walgreens. Right. Because you were going there to get other things. You know what? Honestly, you know what my face cleanser is most of the time? It's leftover baby shampoo because I have run out of whatever cleanser I bought once. And now I'm scrounging around under the cabinets in the bathroom and I found some old like honest baby shampoo. And, And that is literally what I'm washing my face with right now. And then oil valet. And put your arm as high as it will go when you take that picture. If you, not, not, not, not reach to your ear.
Walgreens 买的最温和的什么东西。没错。因为你当时去那儿是为了买别的东西。你知道吗？说实话，你知道我平时用什么洗脸吗？是剩下的婴儿洗发水，因为我把我买过的洁面乳用完了。现在我在浴室柜子底下搜寻，然后我找到了一些老旧的、诸如 Honest 的婴儿洗发水。而，这字面意思就是我现在用来洗脸的东西。然后是玉兰油。当你拍照时，把你的胳膊抬到尽可能高的地方。如果你，不，不，不，不是把手伸到耳朵上。
Reach well above your head and you take that picture. And then I told you, Leon, for the picture we took, you just set your chin on your hands. Oh, that's a good one. And maybe you should do, wait, Cassie, can you take another one? Okay, here we go. One, two, three. That was amazing. See, it's great.
把手高高举过头顶，然后拍下那张照片。然后我告诉你，里昂，对于我们拍的那张照片，你只要把下巴托在手上就行了。哦，那是个好招。也许你应该，等等，卡西，你能再拍一张吗？好吧，我们开始。一，二，三。太棒了。看，这很棒。
It solves all the problems. We know you've got to go. You're busy lady, but we end our interviews with the thing that was on our call sheets. It's called the call sheet questions. There's just five questions. Okay. Here we go. Number one, what was your first job in entertainment?
它解决了所有问题。我们知道你得走了。你是个大忙人，但我们的访谈结束时，通常会有一个我们访谈大纲上的固定环节。它叫大纲问题。总共只有五个问题。好吧。我们开始。第一题，你的第一份娱乐界工作是什么？
Does the rotary count for that $50? Yes. I think it does. Okay. The first time really I got paid. doing stand up. A little man that owned a sandwich shop who saw me emcee for free for somebody in my Sunday school class at the Kiwanis capers. Lynn, can you come and do comedy at my sandwich shop?
转盘电话能算那 50 美元吗？算。我觉得算。好吧。我真正拿到钱的第一次。是表演单口喜剧。一个三明治店的老板，他在基瓦尼斯义演（Kiwanis Capers）上看到我为我主日学班上的某个人免费主持。琳，你能来我的三明治店讲笑话吗？
And I'll give you the door money and I'll make money off the beer. That's the first time I ever got paid. That was my first job in show business. At the sandwich shop. At the sandwich shop for Mike, sweet Mike gave me a shot. And I was, I still fear that somebody told me. I taped it and it'll come out. Because I got, he goes, can you do an hour?
我会把门票钱给你，我靠啤酒赚钱。那是我有生以来第一次拿到钱。那是我的第一份演艺界工作。在三明治店。在迈克的三明治店，好心的迈克给了我一个机会。而且我，我仍然担心有人会告诉我。我把它录下来了，它会播出来。因为我到了那儿，他说，你能讲一个小时吗？
And I go, oh, yeah. I got up there and talked out of my butt for an hour. And it's no telling what I said. I don't know what I was saying. But anyway, that was the first time I got money. Okay. Okay. All right.
我说，哦，行啊。我上了台，胡说八道了一个小时。鬼知道我都说了些什么。我不知道我当时在说啥。不过无论如何，那是我第一次拿到钱。好吧。好吧。好吧。
Our second question is, do you speak any other languages or do you play a musical instrument? No and no. Now, I went to a big little tiny country school that was big in future farmers of America in Homek. I do know how to make a banked Alaska. But I played basketball and Spanish was during basketball practice and they just told me I didn't have to take it because I was tall.
我们的第二个问题是，你会说其他语言吗，或者你会演奏什么乐器？不会，都不会。不过，我曾在一所大型的、微型乡村学校上学，该校在“未来美国农民”组织和家政方面很厉害。我确实知道怎么做阿拉斯加冰山（Baked Alaska）。但我打过篮球，西班牙语课和篮球训练时间冲突，他们只是告诉我不用上这门课，因为我长得高。
And they needed to be. And they wanted you on that basketball team. Yeah. So, yeah, I don't have that. But I am going to try to learn the drums. And Fred Ormison from Serenat Live is trying to help me learn how to play the drums. Fred is a close friend of mine. He is from heaven.
而且他们需要。他们希望你加入那个篮球队。所以，是的，我没有那个技能。但我打算学打德军鼓（drums）。来自《周六夜现场》（Saturday Night Live）的弗雷德·奥尔姆森（Fred Armisen）正试图教我打鼓。弗雷德是我的挚友。他简直是个天使。
From heaven, truly. And he messaged me and was so precious about, you know, I like your stuff and all that. It was so sweet. And I got to meet he and his wife behind the John Mullaney show. But I said, I'm going to be 60 in October. Is it too hard for me to learn the drums? No. I said, I've always loved Sheila E. and Prince.
简直是天使，真的。他给我发了信息，非常贴心地说，你知道的，我喜欢你的节目诸如此类的话。太贴心了。我有幸在约翰·木兰尼（John Mullaney）节目的后台见到了他和他的妻子。但我说，我十月份就 60 岁了。我学打鼓会不会太难了？不会。我说，我一直很喜欢希拉·E（Sheila E.）和王子（Prince）。
And he's a big Prince fan. He made a video for me to start like on a pad. So hopefully the next time I'm on with y'all, I can say, yes, I'm a drummer. Yes, I love that. I love it. Okay, next question. What's a place you've been to that you absolutely loved?
而且他是个超级王子粉丝。他给我制作了一个视频，让我从一个练习垫开始练习。所以希望下次我和大家连线时，我可以宣布，是的，我是一名鼓手。太棒了，我喜欢这个。太棒了。好的，下一个问题。你去过什么地方，是你绝对深爱的？
Oh my gosh, I go so many places that I absolutely loved. Y'all, I've been so many places. Let me think. Greece. Oh, yeah. Mekonos. That was pretty nifty. That's the only place I've been over Europe was Greece.
天哪，我去过好多我绝对深爱的地方。各位，我去过好多地方呢。让我想想。希腊。哦，对。米科诺斯岛。那真是太棒了。我在欧洲去过的唯一地方就是希腊。
That sounds lovely, though. I've never been to Greece. It was islands and, yeah, mecanos, it was beautiful and did not look real. Oh, but I could say Alaska, too. Alaska was beautiful. It didn't look real. You know, it looked like a picture book. All right. Next question. What do you like to do on the weekends? I like to have these grandbabies over and cook what they want and let them go down this Costco Rollers coaster that I bought them. Costco roller coaster.
听起来真不错。我从没去过希腊。那里都是岛屿，而且，是的，米科诺斯岛，美得简直不真实。哦，不过我也可以说阿拉斯加。阿拉斯加太美了。美得不真实。你知道的，看起来就像一本绘本。好吧。下一个问题。你周末喜欢做什么？我喜欢让这些孙辈们来家里，做他们想吃的东西，让他们玩我给他们买的好市多（Costco）滑水道。好市多滑水道。
Wait, I've seen that. I have seen that. You can buy a roller coaster for your backyard. I've seen clips of that online and I kind of didn't know it was real. That's real? Oh, it's like for little kids. Yeah, it's on like probably a little above your ways. It's like a little.
等等，我见过那个。我见过那个。你可以在后院买一个滑水道。我在网上看过那玩意的视频，我当时还不知道那是真的。那是真的？哦，那是给小孩子玩的。对，大概有你腰部那么高。就像一个小型的。
And then your baby. Yeah, like a train thing. And they love it. And it's got a little red car on it and my son will push. And I mean, they will go all the way to the other end of our property. and they go nuts and love it. And I also like to put out, right now, you know, it's hotter than Hades. I just got something from Target probably that I put the hose in and water sports up.
然后你的宝贝。对，就像一个小火车一样。他们超爱这个。上面还有一辆小红车，我儿子会推。我的意思是，他们会一路滑到我们家院子的另一头。他们玩疯了，超级喜欢。我喜欢在外面摆出，现在嘛，你们知道的，天气热得要命。我可能刚从塔吉特（Target）买了个东西，我把水管接在上面，水就会喷出来。
And they put on the swim trunks and go and playing that water. And I like to have toys out there that, you know, like lizards and stuff that they can put in there. And I also bought them some riding toys for the yard. So I always have those. But if I'm not on the road, which most time I'm on the road. But if I'm at home, I like to have all my kids there. I like to go and buy a bunch of good stuff to eat. And I like to cook, everybody cook and do and be together.
然后他们穿上泳裤去水里玩。我喜欢在外面放一些玩具，你知道的，比如蜥蜴之类的东西，他们可以把它们放进去。我还给他们买了一些院子里骑乘的玩具。所以我总是备着这些。但如果我不在路上，虽然大部分时间我都在路上。但如果我在家，我喜欢让我的所有孩子都在那儿。我喜欢去买一堆好吃的。我喜欢做饭，每个人都做饭、做事并聚在一起。
That's my favorite thing. And watch these babies play. I think I can pick out good toys. Yeah, that sounds wonderful. And as a grandmother, you know, as a grandmother now, I can, you know, it's like we were on such a budget. Like they got Christmas and, you know, they had toys, of course. But now I can like go, I'm going to the Costco to get the roller coaster.
这是我最喜欢的事情。看着这些宝贝们玩耍。我觉得我挺会挑玩具的。是的，听起来太棒了。而且作为一个祖母，你知道的，现在作为一个祖母，我可以，你知道的，就像我们以前手头很紧。就像他们过圣诞节时，你知道的，他们当然也有玩具。但现在我可以去说，我要去好市多买滑水道。
and everybody can kiss my foot. We're doing it. You know what? You work hard. You work hard. You should be able to enjoy that hard work with your family. Thank you, my daughter. Nothing wrong with that.
所有人都可以吻我的脚。我们买定离手。你知道吗？你工作很努力。你工作很努力。你应该能够和家人一起享受那种辛勤工作的成果。谢谢你，我的女儿。这没什么不对的。
Yeah. Nothing wrong with that. Last question. What is your favorite midnight snack? Oh, y'all. I do love salty and sweet. Can I say that I would like to start out with something salty? So I do love a chip.
对。这没什么不对的。最后一个问题。你最喜欢的午夜零食是什么？哦，天哪。我确实喜欢又咸又甜的。我能说我喜欢先从咸的开始吗？所以我真的很喜欢薯片。
I don't have a look of a tent. I don't have a look of a tortilla chip. with cheese damp. I do like guacamole. I like salsa, but I do love a cheese dip with a little rotel. But I've got to finish it off
我不喜欢玉米饼。我不喜欢蘸着芝士酱的玉米片。我确实喜欢鳄梨酱。我喜欢萨尔萨辣酱，但我真的超爱加了一点罗特尔（Rotel）辣椒碎的芝士蘸酱。但我得用这个来收尾——
with a dark chocolate with almonds. And if I'm really lucky, I might have a Cadbury Fruit Nut bar near, which I want everybody to have at my funeral. I've always said to my children
黑巧克力配杏仁。如果我真的很幸运，我附近可能还有一块吉百利（Cadbury）水果坚果巧克力，我希望每个人在我葬礼上都能吃到这个。我一直对我的孩子们说
for my celebration of life, I want everybody to come in and get a big size canberry fruit nut bar. If y'all ever had one, you'll lose your mind. Now, somebody told me they're better, they're made in England. If you can get them in Canada, they don't have all this waxy stuff on them. I don't notice the wax. I get mine at Walgreens. If you're, Jen, if you're going in there to try
为了我的生命庆典，我希望每个人进来都能拿到一块大号的吉百利水果坚果巧克力棒。如果你们谁吃过，你们会疯狂的。现在，有人告诉我它们更好，它们是英国制造的。如果你能在加拿大买到它们，它们上面就没有所有这些蜡质的东西。我没注意到有蜡。我在 Walgreens 买我的。如果你，詹妮，如果你要进去试着
to get you to get my oil of halay. Yes. Go to the candy aisle and get the big bar of Cadbury fruit and nut. Now, that's a milk chocolate. I'm a connoisseur of chocolate, but I love that milk chocolate. It's got a fruit and a nut in it and just let it melt. your mouth, you will lose your mind. I don't know if I should even tell y'all that because I don't want y'all to get hooked on it. But I do love a sweet and salty, and I do love, it is fun to eat at night and watch a show. Yeah, have a little treat. I love it. Yes. I think everyone listening needs to go get the Cadbury Fruit Nut and watch Leanne on Netflix. This is it. We're not sponsored by Cadbury, but, you know, feel free to call us.
去买我的玉兰油。是的。去糖果过道拿一大块吉百利水果坚果巧克力。那是一款牛奶巧克力。我是个巧克力鉴赏家，但我超爱那款牛奶巧克力。里面有水果和坚果，只要让它在嘴里融化，你就会疯狂。我不知道我是否应该把这个告诉你们，因为我不想让你们对它上瘾。但我确实喜欢又甜又咸的东西，而且我确实觉得，晚上边吃边看节目太有趣了。对，吃点小零食。我太喜欢了。是的。我觉得每个听众都需要去买吉百利水果坚果巧克力，然后在 Netflix 上看莉安的节目。就是这样。我们没有接受吉百利赞助，但是，你知道的，随时欢迎给我们打电话。
I know. We're probably going to sell a lot of fruit nut bars. Yeah. Leanne, this was a joy. Thank you for making the time. You're so busy right now. And just know you got two gals who are just rooting for you and we're here for you and we cannot wait to just cheer you on. You angel. And thank you for getting me through menopause. Thank you for letting me laugh at that new thing that is the hot flash. Oh, my darling. Thank you so much. I laughed so hard.
我知道。我们可能会卖出很多水果坚果巧克力棒。是的。莉安，这太令人愉快了。谢谢你抽出时间。你现在太忙了。要知道你有两个全力支持你的女孩，我们永远支持你，我们迫不及待地想为你呐喊助威。你这个小天使。谢谢你陪我度过更年期。谢谢你让我把潮热这个新鲜事当笑话看。哦，亲爱的。非常感谢你。我笑得太厉害了。
I sent it to my husband, and I was like, babe, look, I feel seen. Yes. Oh, my, I'm so glad, Jenna. And tell me, is somebody doing your biodentical hormones? You got somebody? I have all the doctors helping me through. My big thing is acupuncture. Oh.
我把它发给我丈夫，我说，宝贝，你看，我被看见了。是的。哦，天哪，我太高兴了，珍娜。告诉我，有人在给你做生物同质性激素治疗吗？你有找人帮忙吗？我所有的医生都在帮我度过难关。我最大的法宝是针灸。哦。
Acupuncture for hot flashes. Oh, good. Yeah. It's working. It's great. Oh, wonderful. And a fan that blows on me at night as you. know about the fan. Oh, y'all are so yummy and precious. Oh, thank you, Leanne. As y'all weren't giving
针灸治潮热。哦，太好了。对。管用。太棒了。哦，太棒了。还有晚上吹着我的风扇，正如你所知道的风扇。哦，你们俩太可爱太珍贵了。哦，谢谢你，莉安。好像你们一直没给我们
us all this Joey all this time. Thank you all so much. I've had a bowl. Thank you so much. We'll be in touch. I want to meet you in person sometime, Leanne. I would love that. We're going to go for a walk. We'll do a walk and talk next time you're in town. Walk and talk, maybe even find a church basement, Zumba or Jazz or something. Yes. Yes. We could do that. There is a Zumba class within walking distance of my house. Okay. So I'm just throwing it out there. Oh, my Lord. Okay.
带来这么多快乐。非常感谢你们。我度过了一段美好的时光。非常感谢你们。我们会保持联系的。莉安，我希望能有机会亲自见见你。我很乐意。我们要去散步。下次你来城里，我们安排一次“边走边聊”。边走边聊，甚至可能找个教堂地下室，去跳尊巴（Zumba）或者爵士舞什么的。对。对。我们可以做到。我家里步行距离内就有一个尊巴班。好吧。所以我只是随口一提。哦，天哪。好吧。
So it can happen. It can happen. Okay. I would love that. Oh, my gosh. If the three of us walked into that Zumba class, I would just love it. People would lose their minds, I think. I mean, how fun is she?
所以这完全可能发生。完全可能发生。好吧。我太乐意了。哦，天哪。如果我们三个人走进那个尊巴班，我简直太爱了。人们会疯掉的，我觉得。我是说，她怎么这么有趣？
I love her. And I seriously, I want us to do a Zumba class together. Lady, I have been wanting to do the Zumba class. And I was going to ask you if you want to, want to do it, but I think the three of us need to do it. I'm serious. I want to do Zumba with you and Leanne. I want to make it happen. I'm here for it. Listen, a big thank you to Leanne for joining us on Office Ladies and for helping us laugh at everyday life. You can catch Leanne on tour right now in her just getting started stand-up show. We'll put a link in stories for her show dates. And of course,
我太喜欢她了。说真的，我想让我们一起去上尊巴课。姑娘们，我一直想去上尊巴课。我正想问你们想不想去，但我认为我们三个人都得去。我是认真的。我想和你还有莉安一起跳尊巴。我想把这变成现实。我奉陪到底。听着，非常感谢莉安加入我们的《办公室女孩》（Office Ladies），并帮助我们对日常生活付诸一笑。你现在就可以在巡演中看到莉安的单口喜剧秀《刚刚开始》（Just Getting Started）。我们会在快讯（Stories）中发布她演出日期的链接，当然，
check out her new TV show Leanne starting July 31st on Netflix. So listen, everyone. before we go, we are off next Wednesday. We're going to be revisiting our interview with Billy Elish, but be sure to tune in on Friday, August 8th for a little surprise. In fact, every Friday and August starting August 8th, we're going to have a little something extra for you. I'd really like to give you a hint, but I can't. Can I do rhymes with?
还要关注她的全新电视节目《莉安》（Leanne），7月31日起在 Netflix 上线。所以听着，各位。在我们离开之前，下周三我们休息。我们将重温我们对比利·埃利什（Billy Eilish）的访谈，但请务必收听 8 月 8 日星期五的小惊喜。事实上，从 8 月 8 日开始，八月份的每个星期五，我们都会为你准备一点额外的小东西。我真的很想给你一个提示，但我不能。我能出一个押韵题吗？
Yeah, do rhymes with. A little bit of schmaper. Yeah, it has to do with schmaper. Oh, okay lady, I have to get packed for Chicago and you have a family vacation to get to. I do. I'm going to Iceland and I'm going to go to that penis museum. Oh, I can't wait to hear about that. All right, everyone. Thanks for listening. We hope you have a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
行，出个押韵题。有点像 schmaper。对，这和 schmaper 有关。哦，好吧，姑娘们，我得收拾行李去芝加哥了，而你也有家庭度假要去。没错。我要去冰岛，我要去那个阴茎博物馆（penis museum）。哦，我迫不及待想听听这个了。好了，各位。谢谢收听。祝你们过得愉快。感谢收听《办公室女孩》。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女孩》是 Audacy 的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubbicoe）。Audacy 的执行制片人是莉娅·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女孩》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《鲁珀特树》（Ruppertree）。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。